hi my name is candice brown and i'm an
assistant professor
at west virginia university in the
school of medicine
today i'll be speaking with you about
some new
unpublished pilot studies in our lab
where we'll be talking about a novel
strategy to investigate
longitudinal changes within the gut
microbiome
and we'll look at some animal models of
sepsis and alzheimer's disease
to address this
as as part of our seminar overview i'll
be going over
the relationships between the microbiota
gut brain axis and the role of sepsis
and alzheimer's disease and
within this axis and how we can study
longitudinal changes that occur within
these disorders
using a gut microbiome sequencing
strategy
next i'll talk about the ribosomal rna
sequencing strategy that we used that
incorporated the 16s
its and 20 and 23s
regions of bacteria and then i'll talk
about
some of our results including changes
in the species and strains that we
observed in our study
to begin i'd like to give a brief
overview of the microbiota
gut brain axis again this is a
bi-directional axis
where you have communication between the
brain and the gut
which is shown on the left and also
you have reciprocal communication
between the gut and the brain which is
shown on the right
within studying this particular axis
it's important
to dissect out what the individual roles
of of each of these directions are
and that leads to several emerging
questions in the field
such as does the brain or the gut drive
this communication
and how does it differ in different
diseases
how does the communication occur in
healthy individuals
how is the communication disrupted in
disease
and for my laboratory how does this
communication affect brain and behavior
my behavior i mean my laboratory is
interested
in the effects of systemic inflammation
on the brain and behavior
so we use animal models such as sepsis
and alzheimer's disease
to address this first i'll go into a
little bit about sepsis
sepsis is described most recently
by 2016 criteria as a life-threatening
organ dysfunction
caused by a dysregulated host to
infection
that's a complicated way of saying that
you that you have an infection
that affects multiple organs some of
those organs
are included here and two of the major
players
as i've indicated are the nervous system
and also
the the gastrointestinal system
and in particular this gut dysbiosis
is um is a major driver of much of the
dysfunction
during sepsis
to to learn a little bit more about
sepsis and why it's important that we're
studying this
i'd like to go over some of the most
important
epidemiological facts about sepsis as we
know today
it is there are 1.7 million sepsis cases
in the u.s
every year and there are multiple risk
factors
the most important of which is age where
most patients are greater than 65 years
old
sex is also another issue where the
incidence is higher in males
and also comorbidities can also
influence
the outcome to sepsis but what's really
important is that although
we've made great strides in actually
treating sepsis
we we have more people who are
developing sepsis
at both older and younger ages
because the incidence of sepsis is
increasing worldwide
so it is a serious public health issue
another important aspect of sepsis is
the timing
of the inflammation and the immune
response
in this graph you'll see by the yellow
arrow
on the on the x-axis that
that the time in days is very important
on the y-axis you'll see the direction
of the inflammatory response
be it hyperinflammatory or
or hypoinflammatory or immune suppressed
the most important thing to note is that
there are
no fda drugs to treat sepsis other than
microbials and supportive care what
would be considered
the standard of care in particular
many patients approximately 10 percent
die during the early early days of
sepsis
during the cytokines storm
but we are interested in the potential
survivors
and we are also interested in the
patients
who actually um who actually die later
and we think that uh that potentially
we can improve survival in these
patients
so this 90 percent of the sepsis
of sepsis patients is is what we'd like
to focus on
in our studies and therefore
this led us to ask the question can we
improve sepsis outcomes in survivors
and decrease mortality by targeting the
gut brain microbiota axis
so first let's begin with the organ
systems that i talked about
previously what we know is that
gut dysbiosis plays a extremely
important role in sepsis
and can be both a cause and a
consequence of sepsis
in the graph you'll see on the top that
you have
micro microbiome diversity that changes
during disease
and as you have multiple and as you have
multiple bouts of illness and infection
you'll see that there's a corresponding
panel
on on the bottom of this graph that
shows that you have an increased risk
of sepsis with um as you have an
increasing
amount of of critical illness
and so once you reach that tipping point
where the gut dysbiosis cannot recover
that actually leads
to sepsis alternatively
we also know that
we also know that gut dysbiosis is a
consequence of sepsis
and affects multiple organ and organ
systems including the immune system
and the kidney and muscle wasting
in our lab we're primarily interested in
the effects on the brain and these are
largely
very poorly understood so how does
sepsis affect the brain in humans we
know
that sepsis alters both short and long
term
cognitive behavioral outcomes and some
studies
published in the journal of the american
medical association
suggest that up to 70 percent of sepsis
survivors
may have some sort of neurological
impairment as shown in humans
in this in this image which demonstrates
it very nicely
is that sepsis doesn't end at hospital
discharge
patients have a variety of long-term
of long-term neurological changes such
as
cognitive disturbances mood disorders
muscle wasting muscle wasting and also
gait disturbances
in addition these are some of these
changes are also demonstrated
by the graph on the right so as you have
increasing sepsis severity you have
additional early signs
of sepsis and then you also have
as shown in the middle i showed in the
middle portion multiple
brain structures that are recruited and
in the more severe stages
you have the hippocampus the frontal
cortex and the brain stem
which are recruited in addition to um
structures of the limbic system which
affect mood
the outcomes as a result of the
recruitment
of these um of these brain systems are
um are numerous most importantly they
range from
um mood disorders um in the least severe
uh forms of sepsis to um
to death you know potentially in the
most severe forms again
we're interested in what happens in
survivors so we're focusing on
what causes some of these mood disorders
and most importantly
what what is the root of the cognitive
decline
we've tried to mimic this in a mouse
model of
sepsis so as shown in the yellow arrow
we have an example from one of our
longitudinal studies
of using wild-type
male mice where we induced a sql
ligation and puncture model
of sepsis which i'll go into more later
at day zero we induce sepsis and then
over a six day
period we um we subject the animals to
multiple
behavioral tests
two of these tests involved locomotor
activity
so as you can see here when we when we
test the animals
using an open field or spontaneous
locomotion paradigm
we can see that both the total behaviors
and the rearing
behaviors are reduced in the septic
animals as shown in red
but conversely when we use a
non-voluntary
behavior such as the rotor rod where the
animals are on an accelerating wheel
and they need and they need to stay on
there is no impairment in their in their
activity because
it's evoked so we think that this may
relate to a motivation factor which is
under
uh which is under study secondly we were
also interested
in analgesic responses which are also
impaired
in some sepsis patients and again
we used um a device known as the hot
plate
where the mouse where the mouse is
placed
on a warm surface for a period of time
and we measure the time
that it takes the animal to actually
move
as shown in the latency and also
the number of nociceptive behaviors such
as licking
and also grooming so you can see that in
the septic animals as shown in red
they have a greater latency to respond
to the warm
to the warm temperature and they have a
decreased number
of nociceptive behaviors which is shown
in panel e
so taken together this mouse model um
shows that in young mice that we can
detect
changes in brain and behavior during
sepsis
next we're also interested in
alzheimer's disease
and and and the relationship between
prior infection and the onset of
dementia
in this study we did a longer term study
we used middle-aged alzheimer's disease
or
ad a transgenic mice at an older age
which would be considered
middle aged in mice which is eight to
nine months old
we induced sepsis on day zero and then
we measured
their behavior at day nine and we
measured their neuropathology
at day twenty one remember in the
present study
that we ended our study at day six
so first of all we used a spatial memory
paradigm
where we showed that
where we showed that that
spatial memory is impaired in
alzheimer's
disease transgenic mice that were
subjected to sepsis
so alzheimer's disease transgenic mice
that that were not subjected to sepsis
are shown in blue
and their septic counterparts are shown
in red and you can see
that on that on day two where they have
to recall what they learned on the first
day
that amount of time is actually longer
in the
in the alzheimer's disease animals
secondly
at day 21 we also looked at their
pathology
microglial activation or microgliosis
is is a cardinal feature of the
neuroinflammatory response in
alzheimer's disease
we looked at microgliosis in two regions
of the brain that are affected in
alzheimer's disease
the subiculum and the internal cortex
these are also affected in humans as
well and what we can show
is that there's a greater activation of
microglia
in the subiculum and in the enter rhino
cortex
this is quantified on the right
and we also found that there are more
microglia
associated with beta amyloid
beta-amyloid plaques which are a
hallmark
feature of alzheimer's disease in the
septic animals
after 21 days and this is lower in the
ad sham animals
so taken together this shows that we
also see changes in brain and behavior
as a result
of sepsis in our ad transgenic animals
this led us to ask the question how does
the gut microbiota change over time
during sepsis and we hypothesize that we
expect to see a sustained loss of
beneficial bacteria as well as an
increase
in pathogenic bacteria our model for
studying this
is very similar to the models i showed
you previously
in our preliminary data we used both
wild-type mice and we use
alzheimer's disease transgenic mice
we had animals that were subjected to
a sham sepsis injury at day zero
or a sepsis injury we used a sql
ligation and puncture model of sepsis to
address this
at day zero prior to surgery we
collected fecal samples
from the mice this is known as the d0
group over a six day period
we also assessed sepsis severity and
behaviors
and at day six we also collected fecal
samples as well
and that's referred to as the d6 group
taken together this gives us four total
treatment groups
um wild type sham wild type sepsis
adcham and adsepsis
where we collected two samples from each
animal
at day zero and six so we can look at
the longitudinal changes
in the gut microbiome over this short
period of time
then we used 16s ribosomal rna
sequencing
to assess some of these changes we use
shoreline microbiomes strain id kit
which takes advantage of um of assessing
and sequencing the 16s region the
intergenic uh transcriptional spacer
region
and the 23s amp uh and the 23 s
region uh to prepare an approximately
2500 base pair amplicon
this gives us the ability to resolve
both both strain
and species differences uh once the anim
uh
once the fecal samples were you know uh
were prepared they were sent
to pac bio um at one of their core
facilities
for sequencing then we used a dota 2
which is an algorithm to infer some of
those amplicon sequence variants
followed by classification of those
amplicon sequence variances
grouping them and and processing um
and assessing the percent identity with
both known
um and also identifying unknown uh
amplicon sequence variances
and then doing further investigations in
chime too
to orient you to our results um i'd
first like to show you
uh what the outputs look like in chime
at the bottom
where you see a yellow arrow i've
actually highlighted
highlighted what those data are at the
top of the screen
so what you'll see is that both samples
will always be paired
with day zero on the left and day six on
the right
and the sample name will also be
embedded within this information
in this case it's sample 32 and the
relative
frequency of of each of the taxa will be
represented
so this is shown here i've shown
you know the relative frequencies of the
of the genera that we found and the top
11
genera are located on the right
and you'll see that the samples are are
also grouped
by the four treatment groups that i
described earlier
um the ad clip adsham wildtype clip and
wild type sham
now i've ac now what i've done is i've
taken um
the graph of the genus level data and
shown
a species level bar plot and here we can
start to dissect
some of the interesting results first
what i'd like to emphasize
is that we identified um is that we
noted
that we had um changes in
or we had a large level of many mirror
baculum species
um as shown by the red um
shown by the red boxes here which are
demonstrated by the blue
and um and the light purple shaded areas
on the graph
secondly we also noted that a
significant portion of our samples
as shown by green and in light orange
are also indicated are also represented
by several lactobacillus strains
i'll go into the significance of more of
these changes
in some upcoming slides but i want to
first emphasize the importance of the
mirror baculum
finding so many of these
mirror mirror baculum species are also
are
actually classified in a family known as
mirror baculae ci this was formerly
known
as in as an orphan family called s24-7
and the representative genera
in this family are mirror baculum and
caniella
for many years um you would find s24-7
as part of your sequencing results but
but more recently this was renamed into
the mirror
murebaculae ci family importantly
what we and others have found is that
this comprises
a significant portion of the mirroring
intestinal microbiome and it's a
commensal bacteria
that is gram-negative in our study
we found that mirror baculum species
comprised nearly 50 to 75 percent of the
healthy mouse gut
and we identified 16 new species
based on sequencing shown on the left
are are the average
distance trees of amplicon sequence
variants
and you'll see based on the different
colors that we were able to identify
both known and novel mirror baculum
species
using our 16s 23s strategy
but conversely when we only um when we
only addressed
um the distances using the v1
v9 16s a truncated
region we don't get the level of
resolution that you see on the left
although we can identify some of those
species
so now we wanted to look at the
differences
between all of our groups so we plotted
them using
principle component analysis
what we can clearly see is that the
samples separate
into two separate groups
when we separated them by sham versus
sepsis surgery and we combined all of
the day six and day zero samples
and the alzheimer's and the and the wild
type samples
we can see two different groups and
there's a cluster of six samples
that are highlighted in yellow
next we looked at the distances between
the
the day zero samples represented by the
small circles
and the day six samples represented by
the large circles
and so the and so the longer the the
distance
represents more um more of a change
within a given um animal between day six
and day zero and again you can see that
the longer distances
are are are in that cluster of six
samples
next we also looked at the treatments um
at the treatment groups and what you um
and separated them
into wild-type sham and sepsis and ad
shaman sepsis and you'll see that this
cluster
of six of six samples
which we refer to as a day six
uh sepsis cluster again is comprised of
sepsis samples
and an equal number are from both our
wild type
and our alzheimer's disease sepsis group
this is what we focused on for the
remainder
of our of our analyses and we asked the
question
what are the factors that drove those
six samples to cluster together
the first question we asked were any
taxa decreased
at day six compared to day zero
so first i will orient you
to our graph plot and what we've done
here
is that instead of separating out the
groups
by their treatment we've actually
clustered those six samples together
as shown um by the red box
and what you can see is that if you
focus on the mirror baculum
um genera
which are all shown in uh what you're
all shown
in green is that the day six sample
uh day six cluster samples have almost
less than five percent mirror baculum
while um all the other samples at either
day zero or day six
have a greater than fifty percent
percentage
of mere baculum species
then we asked whether any taxa were
were increased at day six compared to
day zero
here it was easier to see changes by
by looking at the family level and
that's why the colors are different here
the orange orangish yellow color
uh represents your uh
mirror baculaceae species and what
you'll see
is that in that day6 sepsis sepsis
cluster group
that you have an increased number of um
of uh of a taxa from the claustro dallas
family i mean order and the burke
holdery and the bulk burke
holdery holder eat alleys order as well
and these and these are represented by
three
uh three primary families uh the
pepto streptococc cockadacei
and the claustrodacia families and the
burkhold burkhold arealis uh families as
well
then we asked the question were there
any taxa that had a protective effect
against the clostridale's colonization
at day six so again here
i've switched back to separating our
samples
by the treatment groups and this makes
it easier to see
these changes and the samples
that are in the day six cluster here are
outlined in the red
in the greenish blue boxes what we can
see
is at the genus level that the samples
that have a that have a greater loss
of a mirror baculum as shown in
as shown in green also have a
low level of lactobacillus
at day zero so you can see that by
comparing
the the panel on the left and the panel
on the right
for all of the samples in the boxes and
these lactobacillus species are
represented by
uh lactobacillus murinous rutary
and john sonny these comprise
nearly 98 of all the lactobacillus
samples in our mice what we also found
was that samples with a low
lactobacillus at day zero
are also colonized by several of those
clostridiales families that i showed you
on the previous slide again we're
looking at the genus level
and the lactobacillus samples are shown
in
blue and in the highlighted boxes
you can see when comparing dasier on the
left and day six on the right
that that you have an increase
of both the purple and the orange um
um in the uh and they are in jaw boxes
which correspond to uh some of the
clostridales
um family members
and these are most abundant in our day
six samples with those samples
that had a low lactobacillus at day zero
now because we were comparing both
wild-type and alzheimer's disease
samples we wanted to look at the
differences in abundance
between the wild type and the
alzheimer's disease
transgenic mice using the analysis
of the comparisons between our samples
in in chime 2. and what we
show here is that we can when we compare
all the wild type samples
and all the alzheimer's disease samples
regardless of the day
um or the treatment we can see that um
lactobacillus uranus again
most likely that's a very abundant
a bacteria that's found in mice but not
necessarily
in humans is highly abundant in our
alzheimer's disease
a transgenic animal and there's also
higher levels
of of a novel novel brocol
burkholder diale's
order in alzheimer's mice which as you
can see
are much lower in the wild type animals
we also had differences in some of some
of the
lactobacillus john sonny uh strains
um in a.d versus wild type as well
but importantly we actually saw no
difference in sepsis
species or strains between the wild type
or the alzheimer's or alzheimer's uh
transgenic animals meaning that
regardless of your species i mean
regardless of your genotype you have a
reduction
at least in this pilot study of an equal
number of
of ataxa in both wild type and
alzheimer's disease animals
so to summarize we see an important
signature
in in the gut microbiome with sepsis
where we see a high abundance of
lactobacillus
at baseline which seems to protect
against
um uh colonization by two major um
clostridium uh a clostridium taxa
um colonization
postsepsis we also identified
several novel mirabaculum species
and we identified a loss of mirror
baculum species post-sepsis
that is coupled with an inkling increase
in members
of the cost of the clostridiales order
postsepsis but importantly we also found
that there was
that there were no difference in um in
the abundance
of of an ataxa between our wild type and
our transgenic mice
sepsis so this leads us to the
conclusion
um that potentially since there appears
to be a protective effect
of lactobacillus species um
that that we could look at um at
the administration of lactobacillus
as a as a strains or species as a
as a preventative or a protective
approach
to treat um gut dysbiosis
that's associated with sepsis this has
been tried
um in many uh earlier clinical trials
but we identified some specific
lactobacillus
strains that have not been employed in
some of the earlier clinical trials
so uh so we'd like to look at these at
these further
namely lactobacillus rootary
um and some john sony uh strains that we
identified
in our study so
um i'd like to wrap up with
acknowledging all of the people who
contributed
to this work alison burchasek
is a graduate student in my lab who's
very talented
and spearheaded most of this work
we were also we were also assisted
by shoreline microbiome who performed
the
sequencing and introduced us introduced
us to the strain id kit
and sequencing was also performed um at
the
at the pac at the pac bio core facility
at the university
of delaware and i'd also like to thank
our funding sources from the nih as well
as um
lab roots for inviting me to speak
as part of of the symposium and with
that i'd like to say
thank you for watching and please feel
free to
to contact me if you have any questions
thank you